it's gonna eat some pancakes today like
Etta James I am gonna have a ballot
pancakes happy Valentine's Day folks
let's be real I'm basically at that
point in my pregnancy where I am out
like a light
that's like 7:00 p.m. I don't have the
stamina or the interest really on having
a big romantic date night also I can't
drink so is there really a point so I
thought we'd get things started off a
little earlier this Valentine's Day with
a breakfast in bed I'm talking about
some vegan gluten-free protein red
velvet pancakes oh yes we are taking off
all the sexy buzzwords today folks so
you are gonna want to Instagram this and
put in all of those hashtags I am so
excited for this recipe it's become one
of my absolute fave your hubby is gonna
love it your kids are gonna love it
because come on so guys let's do this
let's make my vegan red velvet protein
pancakes I start by preparing my batter
by pureeing some gluten-free oats in the
food processor until they reach a nice
ground-up flower-like consistency then I
add the O flour to a bowl along with
some unsweetened vanilla almond milk
mashed ripe banana vegan chocolate
protein powder maple syrup cocoa powder
plain almond yogurt vanilla extract and
some pureed beets
and I give it a quick stir then they add
a flax egg that consists of 1 tablespoon
of ground flax seed and 2 tablespoons of
almond milk sat in the fridge for about
an hour give it a good stir and set it
aside next let's make our cream cheese
icing to a bowl i softened some vegan
cream cheese can I add some plain on the
yogurt maple syrup vanilla extract and
some lemon juice and I give that a nice
stir until it all comes together
[Music]
now it's time to get cooking I add about
a tablespoon of coconut oil to a
nonstick skillet and about a quarter cup
of the pancake batter cook until it
bubbles around the edges then give it a
good flip to cook on the other side
now it's time to stack those pop cakes I
stack layers and layers of pancakes with
the cream cheese frosting and I stack
them pretty high because hey it is
Valentine's Day then I talked the whole
thing off with some beautiful
pomegranate arils some vegan dark
chocolate shavings and of course some
maple syrup get in there and enjoy
all right folks me and the baby are
super excited to get into this stack of
vegan gluten free protein red velvet
pancakes oh my god I can't wait so guys
I hope you have a fantastic Valentine's
Day with you and your loved ones if
you'd loved this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with what you're gonna be serving
for a Valentine's Day subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]